defense made the plays all day
i don't know if the offense made any
plays
uh might have been reading their press
clippings that they're so good
uh because they didn't show up today
there was
11 guys that stunk it wasn't just them
it was hasn't been a problem until today
they just the red shirts had so much
more energy in that practice than the
white shirts i think the white shirts
thought there was some something good
after friday and uh they didn't show up
today
bruce arians uh not pulling punches as
he typically doesn't do he makes his
thoughts known and he's not happy with
his offense but everybody else is that's
why we have them at number six on the
preseason power rankings and look chris
arians may just be doing the football
coach thing where the offense isn't as
good right now as he wants it to be it's
still pretty good but not as good as he
wants it to be so he's gonna light the
fire a little bit apply the red hot
poker and try to get them ready for the
saints coming to town or they're going
to town there i got to go check the week
one schedule again either way the two
teams are playing they're going to the
scene
they're going to they're going to the
saints they are two weeks from now 13
days from now we'll find out what the
buccaneers can do but at least for now
bruce erion's sounding the alarm well
yeah i mean there's ebbs and flows
through training camp you know the the
energy can be off hey one team dominated
the offense dominated the 11 on 11
scrimmage two days ago the defense has
had to hear about it now they're pissed
off they're going to be ready to go the
defensive staff throws a few curveballs
at the offense that they're not prepared
for and hadn't seen in training camp so
that's the stuff that goes on the
gamesmanship there also hey offense i
think in a lot of ways
especially if a defense comes out and
you're not prepared for it that's gonna
be something to watch for it's like what
tony dungy said last week i think we
could see some moments of sloppy play
like hey we're preparing for the saints
we're preparing for the saints wait the
saints are playing this defense week one
we we didn't see this in the preseason
oh that's right there is no preseason
they didn't play this last year
wait oh hold on we gotta go to the
sidelines and figure out how to pick up
this blitz or deal with this coverage i
think we're gonna see a lot of that but
regardless i mean the excitement for the
tampa bay buccaneers is as high as i've
ever seen in my lifetime i mean it
really is i feel like it's higher than
even when john gruden went to the bucs
teams and all that it's amazing what
we're seeing right now and i am excited
about that offense and what they have on
that side of the ball certainly but it
is a new quarterback and some moving
parts and all that uh and you just
wonder how long that will gel
let alone
mike the other thing too is just hey
it's a great front seven but that
secondary really struggled last year and
we talked about it was one of the worst
past defenses in football too we need to
see that aspect of their team turn
around too no matter who you got on
offense that's got to be better this
year
yeah and look
how often do you see
one of the greatest quarterbacks if not
the greatest quarterback of all time
change teams still have plenty of gas in
the tank even though he's 43. they get
rob gronkowski out of retirement all the
indications are he's the guy he always
was we'll see whether or not that's the
case but there's a lot of reason to be
excited this is a team that was seven
and seven
with mr 30 30 in a bad way well half of
it in a bad way half of it in a good way
first guy ever with 30 interest not
first guy ever but one of the was he the
first guy ever pete with 30
interceptions and 32 guys first guy ever
charter member how soon we forget jameis
winston uh and and he fell apart those
last couple of games that was the reason
why bruce arian said enough we can't
have a guy this close to the finish line
of the season just start throwing up
interception after interception and just
collapsing and uh you take tom brady you
put him on that team that was otherwise
seven and seven through 14 games and at
a minimum at a minimum chris
they're going to get the seventh seed
the question is how high up do they go
unless brady gets injured and it's the
blaine gabbard show
uh they're getting into the playoffs the
question is
do they win the division
do they
somehow emerge with the only buy that
will be available in the nfc but but
this team i think is going to be
dramatically better
it's a different attitude it's a
different mindset they've got great
weapons that were already there better
weapons than tom brady has ever had
collectively two guys on the field who
will need to be doubled at all times
which becomes pretty hard to do if
you've got evans and gronk still playing
like gronk i mean that that's why i put
them in the top ten that's why i put
them at number six i mean it's obvious
to me
if if guys pick up where they left off
even brady diminished last year and he
was diminished in comparison to past
years yeah i still think he puts them in
a position where they can be one of the
best teams in the conference if not one
of the best teams in the league yeah i
mean i i think there's certainly that
potential is i'm not as like steadfast
i'm going they're definitely getting the
playoffs and all that no i'm not i got
too much respect for the overall sport
of football to just sit here and just go
oh they've accumulated a quarterback and
they got a tight end who didn't play
last year and is banged up and beat up
and now they're going to go to the
playoffs i'm not ready to just like
stamp that i understand the potential
there i do i mean i i get it but i still
i got i got questions yeah i mean like
we've talked about brady didn't win one
damn game for the patriots last year not
one he couldn't make a damn play at the
end of the year so i'm not gonna sit
here and just go oh they got tom brady
watch out fireworks ever i'm not
offensive line there's been an issue
there a little bit running games there's
not not been that so there's questions
there
let alone i don't you know
new team all of that offensive line
questionable gotta go play the saints
week one i mean i could see this offense
kind of getting off to a slow start
and i will say this too i still i think
sometimes we talk about bruce arians and
and and him sometimes like he's like
this bona fide oh i go to the playoffs
coach every year and i want to go hey i
love bruce arians i love his offense but
it's only been one year of like whoa
that was a good team so i there's a lot
there i got to see kind of come together
i see the potential and i'm excited for
it and you know after the new york
giants i mean the bucks they have my
heart they drafted me i loved playing
there i loved that fan base but in my
reality of football i'm just saying i
guess what i'm saying is i have
questions and i just i i wonder if
they'll maybe read their press clippings
too much like they're saying and think
that they're just oh we got all these
names and talent we're going to hit the
ground running i could see them
struggling a little early in the year uh
before they kind of get it going
but that's the thing about this season
we have no idea he's going to be
complacent who's going to be motivated
we've seen nothing and and even when
there's a scrimmage right that it's
limited
information that makes its way out it's
limited video because they're all trying
to protect the bottom of the roster and
and all the games are going to be
playing as to who they release who they
try to get on the practice squad for
covet 19 purposes
this is a complete blank slate going
into week one and we won't know whether
or not a team falls flat whether or not
a team is motivated to go wire to wire
is one of the best teams around we just
won't know but with tom brady and given
that motivation he's had throughout his
career given what he did in the
offseason bringing those guys together
yeah the double-barreled middle finger
of the nfl players association when the
union said stop it
with the
workouts among players until training
camp opens because of the pandemic
brady is motivated he's driven
it's it's who he is it's 20 years no
doubt of the patriot way that he's
bringing to tampa bay and again they
were seven and seven
last year without him right i i think
that i think that they're they're going
to eventually get to where
uh you know he would be if they were in
new england that they will be one of the
teams that that needs to be reckoned
with and uh and he gets to prove that he
can thrive without bill belichick as
bill belichick tries to prove he can
thrive without tom brady yeah no i mean
listen
again yeah brady still got a big time
arm all those things he did in the off
season are certainly
going to be beneficial to that football
team and he's he's great that way he's
fearless he's a great leader uh but you
know again i just i guess where i'm just
trying to be a little
you know a little skeptical it's just
yeah we got to see it all to come
together and and i guess what i do look
at sometimes too is just hey i i the
defense you know we don't talk about
that much this front seven what they got
there i mean when you talk about their
front four
jpp
vita via uh what's his name via vitor or
vitavia i'm so sorry to this
vida veya i'm so peter
i don't mean to do that none of the
above peter
i kill his name all the time and dama
consu and then shaquille barrett backed
up by levante david and devin white
who's a top 10 pick linebacker and two
years ago i mean that front seven you
know despite of the offense and
struggling and things like that if
they're not ready to go week one and
hitting on all cylinders that front
seven should be able to
hey tom you don't got it all down yet
it's all right we can dominate this game
we can hold this offense in the check i
think they might have to depend on that
a little bit and the big thing is
they're gonna have to depend on some
young guys in the secondary who i think
have a lot of talent but they're just
young and unproven and last year led up
a lot of big plays and i think that'll
go a long way too to just seeing how far
this team goes you're a little right
there you're a little high for me at six
oh okay that's usually what i say to you
yes i know
best case worst case for the buccaneers
i don't see super bowl okay i'm gonna
say best case nfc championship game i i
i'm gonna say that's the absolute best
case
worst case
i think like what we saw last year seven
and nine eight and eight just missed out
on the playoffs but i think that's about
as bad as it can absolutely get
how about buccaneers 49ers oh
in the nfc championship game whoa tom
brady taking on his boyhood team the
team that spurned him when he made an
overture back in march and let's say
49ers up 28-3 in the third quarter never
mind
let's say it would be a hell of a hell
of a game where's kyle shanahan the
coach of the 49ers with the offensive
coordinator the falcons but it wasn't
his fault that they blew that lead he
wasn't playing defense and uh i i just
want to be clear on that i don't want to
get you all fired yeah don't get me
pissed off so what do you think what are
you saying you going super bowl winning
yeah i think they can win the super bowl
i'm i'm sorry look how many times do we
have to have tom brady prove to us who
he is and what he can do and how he can
manipulate a defense and with that group
of weapons you know the key is can he
stay healthy and the key is
regardless of where his legs are week
one where will they be week 17 where
would they be in january the aging
process continues it's not like once
football season starts everyone's frozen
in carbonite and their bodies don't
continue to get any more beaten up and
broken down and if he gets hit
if he takes hits if he can't get rid of
the ball quickly he's potentially going
to be just like peyton manning limping
into the station
but also hoisting a super bowl trophy a
few years ago in his final season with
the denver broncos so i think best case
win the super bowl worst case
seven seed and uh and lose uh in the in
the opening round of the playoffs that's
because this team's making put me old
takes exposed yeah well we know you've
been saying it's getting the seventh
season you've been saying he's getting
the seventh season don't worry i'll be
i'm not gonna forget this one if they
don't make it don't you forget i'll i'll
remember don't you worry it won't be tom
brady's fault if it happens okay
all right the buccaneers are trying to
snap a long playoff drought what we're
gonna do when we return we're gonna
draft this year's playoff party crashers
every year there's four five six teams
that make it that didn't who are the six
most likely to make it this year who
didn't last year more pfd live right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports